For every sequel that successfully clawed
its way into movie theaters, there's an unmade
take that wowed on paper but floundered in
development.
The Predator franchise has seen more than
a few proposed sequels hit the cutting room
floor, and we break them down right here.
The concept of pitting Xenomorphs against
Predators first appeared in the anthology
comic book series Dark Horse Presents in 1989.
A year later, Predator 2 further indulged
a showdown with an easter egg of a Xenomorph
skull in a Predator trophy case.
But the "Alien versus Predator" concept didn't
make earnest moves toward the big screen until
1991, when future Hellboy co-writer Peter
Briggs penned a spec script.
Briggs' initial draft, titled The Hunt: Alien
vs Predator, adheres closely to the original
Dark Horse comic penned by Randy Stradley.
Taking place off-world and in the future,
Briggs' script focuses on a clan of Predators
who use planets seeded with Xenomorph eggs
as hunting grounds.
As a challenge, their leader includes a queen
facehugger in the batch of eggs unleashed
on a jungle planet.
As you'd imagine, this does not go well.
In 1992, Aliens magazine reported that Roland
Emmerich was attached to direct, though nothing
came of it.
Emmerich and his creative partner Dean Devlin
were especially keen on the idea of the Predator-Alien
hybrid only hinted at in Briggs' draft.
Fox effectively shelved the project in 1993
after producer Joe Roth left the studio.
In 2002, producer John Davis rejected a treatment
penned by James DeMonaco and Kevin Fox on
the basis that he wanted to set the film on
Earth and move away from the Dark Horse comics.
At the end of Predator 2, an elder Predator
rewards Mike Harrigan with a trophy.
"Take it."
The gift is an antique pistol engraved with
the inscription "Raphael Adolini 1715."
It's a memorable moment that hints at just
how long the Predators have been terrorizing
our planet.
It also raises a whole swath of questions
that, it turns out, were intended to find
answers in a sequel that never materialized.
As director/writer duo Jim and John Thomas
note in the Predator 2 director's commentary,
they were constantly toying around with the
idea of a Predator film set on Earth in a
time before modern weapons.
The brothers have said:
"We played around on the set [with] doing
something historical.
Like, in a time where you had nothing but
steam engines and flintlocks and you were
up against something like [the Predator].
That could be fun."
The brothers' brainstorming sessions never
materialized into anything concrete.
And yet, while we were robbed of a big-screen
Predator period piece, that didn't stop Dark
Horse Comics from picking up the Thomas brothers'
enticing engraved pistol and running with
it.
Published in July 1996 and written by Henry
Gilroy, Predator: 1718 tells the story of
Raphael Adolini, his pistol, and how the Predators
in Predator 2 came to acquire it.
Set in the Bermuda Triangle, the comic paints
Adolini as a pirate captain suddenly faced
with a rebellious crew and an unlikely alien
ally.
Before earning his first screenwriting credit
on 2010's Predators, Alex Litvak worked at
20th Century Fox in the 1990s.
He’s talked about how the studio's attitude
at the time was that you couldn't make another
Predator movie without the original film's
star: Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Responding to this limitation, Litvak pitched
a sequel that envisioned the triumphant return
of Schwarzenegger's Major Alan "Dutch" Schaefer.
Litvak's pitch took place directly after the
events of the original Predator.
As the script tells it, the whole affair from
the first film has been classified and Dutch
is living out his days in exile.
Then, a Predator ship crashes at a remote
location and the government taps Dutch to
lead a spry team of commandos to investigate.
When they finally reach the ship, a group
of Predators emerge with one target: Dutch.
He's the one that got away.
And they've come back to claim their prize.
As Litvak explains, the pitch was a pointed
attempt to seduce Schwarzenegger.
Whether Litvak's proposed script even made
it to the actor is unclear.
In any case, the studio resolved that Schwarzenegger
was still off the table and the pitch never
saw the light of day.
While waiting to work on Desperado in the
early 1990s, Robert Rodriguez wrote a script
for a third Predator film.
An unconfirmed copy of his script has since
made the rounds on the internet, and it is,
to put it mildly, completely bananas.
The story begins on an alien planet, where
a group of humans outfitted in Predator armor
attack a Spanish galleon.
The cloaked attackers overwhelm the ship and
transport their captive, Dutch from the first
film, to a prison planet.
The planet also happens to be a gladiatorial
training ground for "teen" Predators, replete
with, among other things, human-alien hybrids.
Rodriguez approached Arnold Schwarzenegger
about returning to his original role as Dutch.
Supposedly there was even a role in the script
written for Jean-Claude Van Damme.
Rodriguez's script would ultimately morph
into 2010's Predators, thanks to an extensive
overhaul by Alex Litvak and Michael Finch.
However, at the time, Fox passed on the script
because Rodriguez's sequel was simply too
ambitious and expensive.
While working on 2007's Aliens vs. Predator:
Requiem as a visual effects consultant, Liam
O'Donnell drafted a sequel treatment.
O'Donnell's idea for Aliens vs. Predator 3
took place on a future Earth ravaged by climate
change where mankind has reverse-engineered
advanced interstellar travel with technology
recovered from Predator weapons.
However, the fuel that powers this spacefaring
tech is derived from a rare mineral only found
in southern Africa, the last continent free
from the vice grip of the Weyland-Yutani Corporation.
The warming of the planet causes the release
of the original Alien vs. Predator queen from
her icy tomb.
And the film ends with a third act three-way
fight between a Predator, Alien, and human.
The treatment was ultimately scrapped for
two reasons.
First, as O'Donnell puts it: After the addition
of the Predator home planet to Requiem, there
was an assumption that if they did a third
movie, it had to be in space.
Second: Upon its release, Aliens vs. Predator:
Requiem failed miserably at the box office,
basically scrapping any hope for a sequel.
In 2015, Vincenzo Natali tweeted a slew of
concept art for, among other things, a tentative
Predator reboot.
The visual pitch offers a brief glimpse into
what we could have seen: An expressionistic
jungle war zone, a sleek and spiky Predator,
and a brutal gladiatorial showdown.
Natali pitched his take on what would ultimately
become Predators with nothing but a logline:
"Predators hunt humans on their planet."
Natali has elaborated on his visual treatment:
"When I was called in to pitch, there was
nothing.
There was no script.
There was only the notion that this was going
to take place on a Predator planet.
I think there was a Dangerous Game aspect
to it with humans being hunted by Predators.
I met with Robert Rodriguez and some executives,
and I just did a whole bunch of drawings."
Nothing ever came from that bunch of drawings.
And that's a shame, because the idea of the
director of Cube and Splice taking a stab
at a Predator movie sounds like a match made
in sci-fi horror heaven.
In 2010, director Nimród Antal and producer
Robert Rodriguez revitalized the franchise
with Predators, an action-packed sequel set
on an alien planet turned hunting ground.
The honor-obsessed aliens use a planetary
game preserve to test their abilities, hunting
down humans as well as creatures from other
planets.
By the end, only two survivors remain.
As the pair catch their breath at the end
of the film, a new hunt begins, and our heroes
realize that they have to escape.
"Now, let's find a way off this f--king planet."
Despite its obvious sequel setup, a Predators
follow-up has yet to materialize.
Which makes co-writer Alex Litvak's enticing
proposal for a direct sequel an absolute knife
twist.
Litvak has described his pitch for Predators
2 as "Die Hard on a Predator ship."
In Litvak's sequel, Royce and Isabelle let
the Predators catch them.
They are then brought aboard the ship that
the aliens use to transport people to the
planet.
They break out of their cells and as they
attempt to seize control of the ship, Die
Hard in space ensues.
Eventually, our heroes make it back to Earth.
And then, per Litvak:
"We land and realize it's the future!
All along we thought this was happening now,
but what if these guys have been on ice for
300 years?
The hatch opens, and the Space Marines come
in!"
This move would have once again merged the
Alien and Predator franchises under one roof.
As Litvak tells it, although 20th Century
Fox was enthusiastic, his proposed sequel
never got off the ground.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Predator
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.